the party's over the question is who for
the morning after the 148 strong tory
rebellion the night before little mood
for celebration on any side
boris johnson's biggest cheerleaders
arriving for cabinet how wounded is the
prime minister to try and work out how
to make all those difficult questions go
away
boris johnson how do you feel he's a
dead man walking isn't he is it time up
for boris johnson
some around the prime minister admit the
scale of the rebellion is problematic
but others claim triumph it was a good
victory for the prime minister
he won comfortably and now he is getting
on business cabinet this morning there's
a lot to be done
look just how much the prime minister
wants it all to be over thank you by the
way for everybody for all your good work
yesterday because uh which was a very
important day because we were able now
to draw a line
under the issues that our opponents i
want to talk about and we are able to
get on with talking about what i think
the people in this country want us to
vote critics admit their campaign is
done they're not quite forgotten i think
he's won the vote comprehensively and
we're just getting on with the business
so he's the right man to lead the party
into the next election
the possible path for future leaders
still filled with obstacles i'll try not
to run you over thanks are you still
running for the leadership what will
worry the existing number 10 is the
number of threats rebels believe are
still facing boris johnson i think it's
in the balance frankly i think there's a
number of factors at play i think it's
the committee i think it's the
by-election for some not for me
but i know that even some ministers are
torn and they've had private
conversations with me as to to where
they stand on this issue
there are ministers and aides with
doubts yet they continue to work inside
boris johnson's government sky news has
established that at least a dozen didn't
issue public statements of support for
the prime minister despite escalating
pressure on some from number 10 to do so
now the prime minister has a big choice
is he going to sack them and risk
inflaming the already bitter tory civil
war or is he going to be magnanimous and
reach out to the unhappiest parts of the
conservative party
but for now those who might gain from
boris johnson's removal are the most
loyal of all my message is we had a vote
yesterday there was a clear result in
that vote now is the time to get behind
the prime minister to deliver on what
people in britain want to see
[Music]
today boris johnson was back in
parliament fresh from his own battles
tonight honoring falkland veterans a
moment of peace in the tory civil war
but what is the next front tax cuts
brexit a skirmish is never far away
sam coats sky news westminster